Homer Simpson is no longer strangling
Bart The Simpsons have really fallen off
huh except for the fact that Homer
hasn't been strangling Bart for years so
here's a summary of how this all goes
down years ago like probably almost half
a decade by now The Simpsons stopped
using the Strangling bar gang fast
forward to a month or so ago The
Simpsons airs a new episode in which
there is a small joke about Homer no
longer strangling fart because I don't
do that anymore times have changed Weeks
Later from what I can tell the Twitter
culture crave tweets saying Homer will
no longer strangle Bar times have
changed and with that every single news
Outlet in the universe took the story
and ran with it but again it hasn't been
a gag for years it was literally just a
throwaway joke where by the way the
punchline is that strangling kids was
obviously not okay even in the '90s so
it has nothing to do with times changing
or woke culture or whatever you want to
call it why do regular people have to
correct trusted news outlets your guess
is as good as mine